SCOTT OAKE AND T TKEPT IN WAY
UP AHEAD FOR WATSON ANDHUK, STÜ
MOVING TOWARDS THE PUCK. DOWN,
WHAT HE DOES, HE COMES OUT AND
ACTUALLY DOES PUT PASS OUT.
HYMAN HEADING TO THE NET!
COUL
DEREK RYAN, NIFTY FACEOFF IOUSL
COUPLE INJURIES AGAINST CALGARY
ON THURSDAY, BUT IT'S ABOUT
FEEDS THE POINT.
IT'S DARNELL NUR HAS BEEN A BIG
IMPROVEMENT HERE NOW MID-SEASON
IN THE BATTLE.LOOKING TO CONNEC
WITH SANFOR
AND TO
TRY AND PICK ONE OFF A
TWISTING  --
A LITTLE BIT DELAYED IN ON JANU
LAST YEAR AND IT WAS AN 8-5
>> Harnarayan: BOUCHARD TEED ONE
UP AND THE REBOUND!
WHAT A FANONE, AND THEN
FOEGELE FROM APASS, STILL
GOT IT TO BRANNSTROM, OFF OF
TIERNEY'S STICK AND NOW IN TO T
GAUDETTE SHOT BY SKINNER AS HE
HAS TO
DROPPED TO THE PUCK.
OVER TO DRAKE BATHERSON.
COMING UP TO IT  ON THE
ICE, SHUFFLING THINGS UP.
HERE'S ANOTHER PLAY.
THEY GET TO A PUCK FIRST IN THE
OFFENSIVE ZONE.
CODY CECI AND IT DIDN'T PAN OUT.
MANO-A-MANO OF
JOSH NORRIS AGAIN AND IT'S
CHABOT AT THE
IT'S A LITTLE BIT TIGHTER BUT
I'LL TAKE IT AND PUTS E
NET.
THEY'RE TRYING TO WHACK AWAY AT
IT.
THE SE OTTAWA
SENATORS.
GOOD DEFENDING IN TIGHT AS IT
LOOKS LIKE EDMONTON HAS